now you have a people there's color
breaking news Kim Kardashian and Kanye
West
do you have color in their house so I'm
cleaning up for the night and just
because you guys always say my house is
so like minimal well you guys haven't
seen my clay room yeah they may live in
a minimalist neutral mansion that feels
more like a museum than a home they can
just took fans on a tour of her kiddos
playroom and it is a floor-to-ceiling
toy build wetterlund
this would make kids have fun on
Wednesday Kim hit up Instagram to show
fans where her four kids North st.
Chicago and saw him play and it is epic
like let's start with the fact that
there's a freakin mini concert stage so
we have our stage here where the kids
often have a band I mean I guess I'm not
that surprised their dad is Kanye West
after all but just check out all those
instruments we have our sing-along
microphones and violins the kids play
instruments north plays violin when
they're not feeling music they can watch
their favorite movies over here is our
projector so they watch movies while
they sit in the playroom they each have
their own section of the room we have
some section over here of just all the
little toys North's like oMG dolls that
she's obsessed with this is kind of
Saints area this is shiz world over here
you know for your ice cream parlor her
grocery store and you can like actually
ring people up in the grocery store
it's like really crazy how do you turn
this thing on
it's so cute okay wait
shy section is definitely my favorite
her washer and dryer her kitchen this is
her whole area her shopping carts and
then all the food and everything's in
here and her tea sets but back to that
little grocery store setup it has an
actual scanner you guys I have to show
you in her little grocery store you have
to see look it goes down the line and
then you like ring things up and then
once you type in like whatever you go on
this side and you have to like sign your
name for the products but it's not just
all fun and games they also have a
designated area to do their schoolwork
this is where they do their homework all
in here's organized educational staff
for their homework that they sit and do
here they have rocking horses yeah
horses plural like I see for a mini
slide and ball pit a dollhouse baby
carriages a whole paint section and the
costumes you guys so we have an entire
costume section like everything like
this is just all head pieces and crowns
this is our Moana Hawaiian section very
animal section shoes princess shoe
section but as a grownup woman watching
this playroom tour it's really the
organization that has me like all up in
my feels Marie Kondo eat your heart out
you guys have to see me up this whole
organized situation of slime and bubbles
and crayons all
colour-coordinated please supposed to be
we try to keep it clean
stamps markers everything I mean that
sparks joy so it's a pretty organized so
pretty organized area all of a sudden I
feel like I have a desperate need to go
to the Container Store anyway back in
December Kim opened up about having four
kids in her all-white home during an
appearance on ellen their rooms are
really festive and wild and everyone has
loom and so i let them go crazy in their
room and the playroom that's smart yeah
that's right so they respected they
respect the space everywhere else and
this isn't the first time kim has given
fans a glimpse inside her in Kanye's
home on in stuff i'm gonna give you guys
a tour of my fridge
kim recently showed off her giant fridge
and it is goals I have walk-in
refrigerator where we keep all of our
fresh organic produce we are building on
the property all organic
trees to grow our own vegetables and do
all of our own stuff and wait until you
see her pantry so you'll come into my
pantry I hope I got rid of all my
plastic so it's all like glass jars even
all my sprinkles and stuff from my
frozen yogurt all that hot take here
that's not a pantry that's an apartment
so you come in the pantry all there is
is the frozen yogurt machine yeah so you
get the point it's freaking awesome it's
amazing of course you can count on ET to
bring you all the latest on Kim Kanye
and the whole Kardashian Jenner crew so
make sure to keep it locked right here
until next time I'm Hallie Stevens I'll
see you soon
[Music]